et si le remède miracle contre la
pandémie venait d anticorps de l'ama
développés par les scientifiques de
l'institut de recherche vieille by de
l'université de gand pour le compte de
la société et xavière bio le médicament
présenterait des résultats prometteurs
sous les animaux de laboratoire pour
débuter les tests sur des patients 23
millions d'euros ont été levés par le
laboratoire
[Musique]
nous travaillons avec des anticorps de
l'ama les anticorps ce sont des produits
que le corps fabrique contre une
infection ou contre un vaccin
nous utilisons notamment les anticorps
produits par des lamas car ils ont une
sorte d'anti corps bien spécifiques
nous pouvons isoler un élément de cet
anticorps et cet élément on peut
l'intégrer dans un anticorps humains
donc nous constituons des sortes
d'hybrides est composée d'anticorps de
l'ama et du moment de nombreux tests
concluants sur des hamsters ont déjà été
réalisées viendront ensuite des tests de
sécurité pour passer le plus rapidement
possible à son utilisation sur l'homme
les scientifiques insistent le
traitement étudié au laboratoire de gand
n'est pas un vaccin mais bien un
médicament un accent c'est pour prévenir
nous travaillons sera un traitement donc
c'est une fois que vous
vous avez été diagnostiquée où vous avez
été en porte contact avec d'autres
alors vous aurez besoin de d'éviter que
le virus se rend dans vos cellules
c'était une finale qui a été très rapide
grâce à tout le travail que la vie est
belle avait fait avant en général quand
on fait une spin out vous êtes à trois
quatre cinq ans de la clinique ici en
six mois on sera même moins que six mois
entre en clinique
premier objectif pour le laboratoire
soigner les patients gravement atteints
par le virus est pris en charge par les
hôpitaux
deuxième objectif utiliser ces anticorps
de la main à titre préventif ou en guise
de traitement pour des patients n'étant
pas encore gravement atteint par les
coronavirus spécialisée dans l'étude
technique des anticorps
ce laboratoire belge s'active chaque
jour pour peut être mettre fin à l'une
des pires crises sanitaires de ces
dernières années